I prayed every night please YouTube
please please send me gold and play
button pin him and being a good boy I
got a lot of subscribers you know
YouTube you really oughta [ __ ] notice
me I'm the biggest channel why don't I
have a golden play but then my numbers
kept growing from millions to ten
millions and I thought at least I'd give
a give a get a diamond play button but
who cares who really cares about a
diamond play button when you can have
gold where do I put this down damn it
all these channels that are Beus airplay
button I'll cut it in half well smash it
with a hydraulic press well I finally
got it I got my play button and then we
all know what happened that day when the
Fire Nation attacked
sorry just when I got my play button and
[ __ ] broken congrats for surpassing 1
million oh that's cool that happened
years ago give me forty four of these
that was broken just like my heart it
was too hard for me to deal with and I
had to sell it I had to sell my golden
play button to a random stranger
today it all changes got a package from
you two let's look oh yes fine finally
huh finally it's here oh I'm so happy
wait the [ __ ] is this PewDiePie what
what am I gonna do with this that's not
the one I wanted
hey Romanian 5 pounds in it's yours well
you know what a Twinner will be just
fine Thank You Romanian goodbye I don't
ever want to see that [ __ ] thing
again disgusting
wait what is this
could it be ah another package from
YouTube
[Music]
can't reach
please
that'd be the one
[Music]
yes yes if you work hard and if you
create a second channel and bitching up
to YouTube about it you will actually
get the jacksepticeye to my favorite
channel ah I've been subscribed since
the very beginning such a big fan of
jacksepticeye - it's such a great
channel it's just such a great [ __ ]
channel oh I see my own face in it and
it's beautiful
oh you Irish piece of [ __ ] this is going
right here
where everyone can see it that looks
really nice
that's gonna be in all my videos now how
about that jacksepticeye forgot what
this video was about um we got a golden
play button finally the golden play
button that we deserve I never felt
disempowered as a woman I want to thank
all my viewers all my sceptic eyes
without your support I could never have
done this it means the world to me you
know when I started doing my channel I
never expected that it would get a
million subs it's just incredible I
don't know I'm I'm just so appreciative
all your support and the fact that we
this really shows it in one plaque this
plaque means so much it's not just a
plaque it's a statement
and that statement is jacksepticeye is a
little [ __ ] I'm sorry this is too funny
it makes me so it makes me it makes me
genuinely happy so yeah let me know what
other channels we should make next and
I'll see you bros in the next video as
always stay there and stay awesome
septic lies
[Music]
you